great to be back at london's foremost
nazi comedy night um
i didn't even follow certain sections of
the media but this is where all the hip
young nazis hang out so
that's cool this is if hitler came back
this is what it do by the way to start a
monthly comedy night on a tuesday so
it'd warm me up with a few dick jokes
and bam hit you with the juice off so
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is a
comedian and a friend of us from comedy
circuit days nick dixon welcome to the
show good to be here how's it going it's
great to have you on listen we obviously
know you very well but for anyone who
doesn't know you tell everybody a little
bit about who you are how are you where
you are what has been the journey
through life that leads you to be
sitting here talking to us wow the
journey okay
i'm nick dixon i'm a comedian uh
and i do
things like gb news right for spiked bit
of talk radio all the things that the
comedy world hates i do them all
and um the journey you know i just i
started doing comedy 10 years ago doing
open mics like everyone else with
mentally ill people and then i um
and then you moved up to the circuit
with mentally ill with other mental
people getting paid slightly more yeah
yeah and that's how it works and now i'm
here today what a journey with mentally
ill
right exactly so yeah it's just
different levels isn't it um but yeah
that's about it i mean you know that's
the whole story i do comedy and other
bits
right short podcast wasn't it
nailed it
but listen the reason we wanted to get
you on i haven't been doing any comedy
for the last two years francis is
working up towards doing it all but
again hasn't really been doing the
circuit right and because of that that
distance i think has given me like a
layman's perspective almost where i'm
like looking on twitter or turning on
the tv once in a blue moon and seeing
like new the new version of the match
report and just going like the question
i think a lot of our audience have in
their mind is like why is comedy on tv
so [ __ ]
yeah well i know what you mean it's
there's this there's this divide now
isn't there between i'll tell you what
that was really interesting the other
night we were doing a comedy unleashed
pilot do your audience know what comedy
unleashed is yeah yeah yeah okay so but
it's worth it there'll be because we've
got friends it's a free speech comedy
night in london yeah done yeah it says
we were doing it in east london in
bethnal green it's quite interesting we
were filming a pilot to try and get on
the tv and on the same night by chance i
found out by pure chance they were
filming live at the apollo in west
london over in hammersmith and i was
like this is the this is the divide in
live comedy so you've got the divide
between the bbc
which is you know some of the comedians
are good but it's the criticism would be
why are people on there are they good
enough to be on there and then you've
got us over here trying to do our thing
and there's criticisms of both of them
but that's this weird divide in live
comedy where people like you say people
think the
comedy on bbc is a bit rubbish so we're
trying to do something different but to
be fair i'm trying to be really fair
there are actually some good comedians
on that as well i wasn't saying there
aren't brilliant comedians on the bbc
what i'm saying is the standard of some
of the things that you see on there is
very low way too low for a production
with that sort of budget with access to
every comedian that they could possibly
want they don't seem to be picking the
best is all i'm saying in every position
it's like a football team that's got a
great striker but the defense is useless
for example right you know what i mean
yeah i know you mean i've been in i've
been in huge trouble for suggesting that
we should just pick comedians based on
their ability alone as individuals no i
got in trouble for that i know it's a
crazy idea isn't it that's controversial
now but yeah i suppose yeah i mean look
i try and stay out of it now i just do
my thing but yeah there is a criticism
that the bbc are not picking the best
people because they're using other
criteria
to select them i don't know what what do
you think the reason is
i'm being very i'm being good
when i was in the game right i sort of
had an idea of what that was but it's
been two years i genuinely don't know
all i see
if in my own experience and this is
again i maybe i was a little bit too
full on when i said i was [ __ ] and
whatever some of it is [ __ ] but my main
thing is i'm seeing people on tv that
when i used to run a comedy club would
email me in to ask for an open spot and
i would say you're not quite ready
yeah and i'm seeing those people now on
television
yeah they haven't really improved right
so the question i think
for me is how has that happened but for
an ordinary person who just watches tv
and thinks that's what comedy is i think
they're asking themselves how is this
happening
yeah yeah and it's obviously because
there are other criteria there might be
other reasons they get picked other than
their ability then they've got the right
agent
you know they're the right flavor of the
month type thing whatever the reasons
are and i'm sort of you can tell i'm
slightly reluctant to speculate on them
because i got cancelled for doing almost
exactly that
[Laughter]
quite recently it is still quite recent
so i still i'm still feeling that pain
so i'm kind of being a bit cautious on
saying what the reasons are but we can
all imagine what they may be but they're
not always who the best comedians are
some of them are and then they get
through and then you can play if you
complain about it like well what about
this guy and they cite one person who is
like is actually good and you're like oh
yeah fair enough so you know you can you
sound you sound bitter talking about it
and i'm not busy because i'm not even
trying to get on that stuff but yeah it
they're definitely there's definitely
a low lowering of quality on the bbc and
they've seen it in the viewing figures
you know apollo used to be a big deal
didn't it with michael mcintyre everyone
watched it
now it's something that is on bbc two
isn't it not and barely anyone watches
it well certainly the the
the viewing figures have gone through
the floor
why do you think there are certain acts
who are genuinely legitimately brilliant
that we see week in week out and they do
very very well but television isn't
interested in them they don't even get a
sniff of it
yeah they're not seen as as sort of
viable it tends to be older acts who've
been going a long time they're very good
but they're not new they're not they're
not
cool and they're not got the right agent
and they're not the right you know they
might not be
diverse whatever it is so that's what it
comes down to mainly isn't it and um
and a lot of people notice this
difference between uk and america where
in america they seem to respect
comics who've been going a long time who
are really good
and we don't have that we just don't
have that we don't actually respect
stand up as a medium in this country
it's not the end of the world i'm not
going to write an open letter but you
know we just don't respect it we've seen
with norm macdonald people like that
we've seen louis ck before the incident
or the respect bill burr the respect
that people have for comedians in
america for stand up it's an american
medium so they have massive respect for
stand-ups who've been going a long time
and like really good and like killers
and it's all about are you are you a
killer in the clubs we just don't have
that here we don't have any respect for
that i don't think
and why do you why do you think that is
why do you think we don't respect the
people who have been doing it for
donkeys years who then are just
master craftsmen at what they do
yeah i don't know i generally just think
it's we just don't understand the medium
in america there's a tradition going
from like richard pryor
onwards this kind of confessional medium
it's an american medium we just don't
have that i don't know where stand up go
in this country i'm not sure where it
comes from it's a mixture of like music
hall working men's clubs and then
there's like the oxford satire tradition
there's these different traditions but
we just don't seem to respect stand-up
we don't i don't think we really know
what it is i don't think tv but they
discovered what it is with michael
mcintyre i don't think they really get
it and i don't i don't think they get
what great comedy is and that actually
the audience would love to see these
people we've all seen in the clubs who
smash it who are older
probably they'd love to see them the
audience but they just don't get a
chance because tv people are only
interested in who the new cool person is
it's interesting because we talk about
representation a lot and we were just
talking about this here in the studio
before you came
but actually like some a comedian that
nobody watching this will have heard of
like jeff innocent
is an older white uh guy
right
he he represents way more people than i
know a russian immigrant or whoever else
but but me being on on that would be
considered diversity whereas him
wouldn't or be considered representation
where's he do you i'm getting that
there's a big constituency there that i
would argue is probably underserved by
what's happening at the moment yeah yeah
because i mean the reality is it's
something like an 80 something percent
white country he would probably talk to
loads of people in the country but yes
but he wouldn't be allowed on probably
so that's why we get things like other
channels isn't it probably like gb news
and all these other channels because the
bbc is arguably not serving people
even though that's their job and we're
all giving them money to do it right
we pay for it don't i mean unless you
just don't pay
which we won't go into
but you know like that's why i realize
this is going on the internet yeah yeah
no i pay i pay i'm saying there's other
people in the country
i've heard
they just don't let anyone in when they
come to the door but actually will
people know their country if the people
are watching all their countries would
they even understand the license fee
it's such a bizarre thing like to try
and explain isn't it to other countries
yeah it's like well you basically they
come around and they make you pay to
watch tv you're like i'm sorry they make
it yeah you have to pay it you have to
pay it yeah even if you don't want to
watch it yeah yeah it's not it's not
weird it's like we have to pay for this
tv channel or we well usually you can go
to jail allegedly i'm not sure they got
that anymore but there's a big fine
isn't there well yeah there is and then
you know and they always end up cutting
some old granny off to the you know
and putting her up there because she
hasn't had the money to pay in the last
two years yeah i just like that bonkers
i mean you're trying to explain that to
people you have to pay this and and and
what's really extra weird is that all
the comedians and people on the bbc then
berate the audience for being brexit
voting scum and it's like they're paying
your wages
isn't that strange
and are you in favor of the b
well i've got to be so careful because
what if there's still a very tiny chance
i might get on one day but uh i almost
certainly won't at this point um am i in
favor of it i think it i'm not in favor
of the license v model i don't i think
it's anachronistic and sort of
communist it doesn't really make any
sense so i mean i mean i don't mind the
bbc but i don't see how the license fee
can work uh in 2021
we i don't think it can work in 2021
when you look at all the different
competitors when you look at amazon when
you look at netflix when you look at all
these different platforms producing
really great content and you know the
bbc still does some things which are
very good but you look at the vast
majority of stuff taking comedy as an
example and it's it's low quality right
right and the idea that you have to pay
for it now
it just seems that yeah out of touch
like you say yeah you've got netflix
amazon yeah so i think i'll be in
trouble that's why you've got gb news
now you've got talk tv coming out you've
got other people trying to compete how
do you feel about those channels well
we've both been on gb news i like gb
news you know and you know there's
things that i disagree you know that
they've done that i disagree with but
there's things that every organization
has done that i disagree with why do you
think that everybody in comedy sees uh
the
the start of gb news is the coming of
the fourth right or the fifth right or
whatever it is it's bizarre isn't it if
you look if you look at brexit was the
fourth right yeah
we're on to the fifth now yeah or the
sixth oh i don't know isn't that crazy
so you've both been on yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i'm a regular on there yeah and i make
sure to tweet it as well so they'll
[ __ ] know about it in the industry oh
good i've seen you on there on once on
on think mark's show yeah yeah i've been
on quite a few times as well it's funny
isn't it the the the outrage about gb
news and all the boycotting and all this
stuff it doesn't make any sense that if
you actually look at what it is it's
actually just an incredibly liberal
channel isn't it it's got like free
speech it's got massive diversity isn't
it just incredibly liberal
well if you look at the old school
meaning of the term liberal then i would
argue that yes it is incredibly liberal
they have you know it's it's they try
and have a plurality of views on that
they have a diversity of uh of
presenters you know you get all
different genders races etc etc yeah
i'll turn i'll be like i'll turn onto
the dreaded gb news and it's three gay
guys and a trans person discussing like
vaccine passports openly i'm like what's
the problem here guys
what have i missed it's like this is not
this far right channel you know that and
i actually think that they kind of
know this this is one of my little
theories is they they know that it's not
actually that bad but but a certain part
of say it just screams loudly if the
overton window tries to get pushed an
inch to another side you know i mean
they're like no no and they scream that
loudly because they don't want any
change it was actually if it was if it
was really i almost think if it was
really bad it would be allowed if you
notice how like people like richard
spencer seem to be like allowed like
they stay on twitter he's quite extreme
figures whereas something like gb news
which is actually not extreme at all it
was just meant to be an alternative to
the bbc that isn't quite meeting its
remit they all scream about it i almost
think it's because it's
quite moderate that it's actually more
of a threat do you see what i mean yeah
so the you know because it's more
mainstream because it actually might be
appealed to a whole section of society
who feel that they've been underserved
to actually have pretty mainstream
opinions
it's more of a credible threat and
therefore it's more likely to be
attacked that's why i think because why
else i mean
if it's got these terrible viewing
figures they all keep pointing out oh do
you believe no one watches it and it's
terrible it's like why are you talking
about it every day though yeah do i mean
if it's just rubbish and ignored why are
you constantly tweeting about it i mean
i also think that you're tweeting
because you're on it yeah
he's com i mean it's it's also the fact
that i think outrage is just it's
rewarded in the current climate if
you're outraged about something it's
gonna get the views the clicks the
whatevers
um and obviously gb news had some issues
with the launch to put it mildly so that
that would have contributed but listen
let's go back to talking about you a
little bit because you mentioned uh
being canceled so to speak
what happened what did you say nick did
you did you say that we need more nazi
comedy or that was it yeah yeah i made a
big push for nazi comedy
[Laughter]
where every punchline is it george yeah
yeah they'll just clip that out now see
[Laughter]
what i did i did a terrible terrible
thing guys i am someone messaged me
a fan a fan if you like someone tried to
get me on a gig which i didn't ask for
but they just said they just out the
kindness of their own heart then they
sent me the message and said oh i tried
to get you on this gig but here's what
the guy said and the guy had said
something like
i like nick or i'm aware of nick he said
he said i'm aware of but
quite a big difference he exists uh i
believe i believe he exists but
but
we we're we're not really booking too
many straight white men
and he said something like i should have
got exact phrase but he said something
like for one of a better not that we're
going he said i'm we're kind of looking
for the opposite and he goes and when i
say opposite i don't necessarily mean a
gay disabled black woman in a wheelchair
or something like that this was it this
was not my quote by the way this was his
so he goes we're looking for the
opposite and we're not really looking
for that and i just thought this is a
bizarre message and kind of funny so i
just shared it with all
identifying information taken out right
so you couldn't find out who this guy
was i just crossed out any possible
things i'm not in the business of
starting pylons against people so i did
that and i just put it like a very wry
tweet
it was something like i should get it
right but it's something like i dream of
a day when i'll be judged on the content
of my character or at least the content
of my content so it was a right allusion
to martin luther king you guys get it
but i thought this will get like 40
likes which it did
and nothing of it right it's this it's
just a minor tweet i was like i received
this pretty funny you know nothing but
then the daily express picked it up
[Laughter]
it's just
just
yeah yeah because you know how this goes
the daily express picked it up and then
i was like oh so i said a couple of
things to them foolishly thinking well
i'll just say something and then of
course it comes out in a crude sort of
tabloidy way and like well i didn't mean
it like that and then
and it looks was the headline like
something nick dixon says white men
can't do comments yeah exactly exactly
yeah a straight white man complains that
straight white men are getting straight
white gigs or something like that this
is something ridiculous and i'm like oh
and then
i was like oh because i thought should i
do this nine times out of ten i would
say no it's not worth it then i just
thought let's just see what happens
definitely found out the answer to that
so stuff happened so then so then the
the telegraph getting touched me i'm
like oh the telegraph now and i'm like
i'm not going to talk to him i'm just
not going to talk to anyone and my mate
said well they'll just print it anyway
which they did
then i get a message the next day you're
on the jeremy vine show i'm like oh it's
on everybody but no not saying and
they're defending you which would have
been the key piece of information i just
got you now on jeremy vine so it's just
escalating and i'm going oh
apparently they were defending me and
jeff norcott was on there like a legend
defending me so
actually all the both the papers and the
and the show defended me but
yeah it's just it was just an escalating
thing that i don't know if you've been
in one of these things you probably have
but they get out of control i have yeah
you've been in one yeah it you know how
it just escalates and and you're just
thinking what now and you can't really
handle it i didn't know how to handle it
because you're just one person and the
whole int suddenly the whole company
industry is attacking me it's a national
news story my tweet it's absurd and it
just and you don't really know how to
handle it i sort of had a stress
response because how can your body
really process what's going on and even
though logically i'm like this is just
happening on the internet and i had
everything muted
logically that's the case but but sort
of physiologically i was sort of
freaking out it was hard for me to sleep
and stuff because it was like it was
really stressful because i had comedies
messaging me are you okay you ever had
that
regularly
yeah yeah yeah i saw the last interview
on trigonometry yeah are you okay yeah
yeah are you sure
when i mean you used to be such a nice
guy yeah yeah one guy messed me then
another a friend of mine was actually
messing with me and i thought this guy
never asked if i'm okay i won't even say
it as well i was like this is
there must be a problem jeremy and
another friend just goes oh i just got i
saw the chortle piece i'm like the what
i know i hadn't even read it so actually
what i've admitted to mention and this
is i don't get two in the weeds of
comedy but there's this comedy website
called blog blog blog yeah there's a
comedy blog
called chortle i can tell you guys love
it already and um it's
everything was fine until they picked it
up so actually everyone ignored that
express piece they completely ignored it
it was only when the when shortly said
hey guys look at this idiot that we can
attack now which was probably
specifically done for that purpose so
then the whole comedy industry attacked
me and then i got all the communities
saying are you okay and some quite big
comedians attacked me
including ones that i'd always been nice
to and about my whole life
and i got on with them one of them would
even give me a nice quote about my
comedy and then he threw me under the
bus to nearly
400 000 people
which i thought was
interesting and this is somebody goes on
about mental health awareness all the
time and even someone who
admitted they were suicidal because
their tv show got canceled and they got
attacked a few years ago and i'm like
but now you're doing it to me i'm like
that blows my mind that someone can do
that
the lack of empathy you know i mean from
the hashtag be kind brigade so nick
what i don't really i mean i think for a
lot of people watching i don't think
they really would understand what what
what what you've done wrong there you
pointed out that somebody who who books
comedy
had said i know that nick is exists
and aware of him i'm aware of him and
presumably that he's good at comedy
but i won't book him because of his
demographic characteristics right is
that what they basically said that's
what they said and you
made people aware that that had happened
so what have you
what what boundary have you crossed
there like
where's the right wing bigotry and what
you've done there is what i'm trying to
get at right right and that's the
interesting thing no one has been able
to ascertain what i did wrong that's
what i'm and everyone's who everyone
normal who's looked at it like normal me
not in comedy has looked at it and gone
what did you actually do yeah and i've
gone great question great question i
talked about on talk radio and mark
dolan he's like what have you done the
only offensive part comes from the
promoter who's written a gay disabled
woman in a wheelchair it's like you
haven't said that i know so it's like
what have i actually done mine was the
old-fashioned liberal notion that we
should be
we should be judged as individuals
call me naive right but i was saying
that if you had two
gay comics on a bill for example let's
say andrew doyle scott caprara just two
examples we might know
i would never say oh it's too good
people they can't be on the bill because
i would just see them as in the
completely different acts right but
they've got completely different styles
right so it never occurred to me i just
think well let's put them both on i just
say put everyone on i don't
who cares about that the individual
style is what matters in comedy because
it's it's about the individual persona
right that's what i thought so that's
all i was ever saying
that is the liberal position but that
now gets you
called a bigger online by a lot of
people and and especially comedians yeah
it was shocking i muted like i say as
much of it as i could but one sentence i
did get i did see one thing that said
yes nick dixon is a bigger but i was
like i'm sorry
what
and it's just like i just couldn't
believe it because i'm just going
that's someone defending yeah yeah
i know there was a book yeah yeah and it
was like
but the sentence almost didn't make
sense to me after a few days of not
sleeping and looking at all this stuff
you're going like it almost the words
didn't even make sense because you see
your name taken so out of context i
never know i'm just a nice guy everyone
knows that and i'm seeing this going
nick this there's a bit i'm just going
who is this guy nick dixon so i i it was
so divorced from reality and it got so
out of hand but i was like what was
bigoted and what i said i just couldn't
figure it out i was even i was saying
let's just base it on merit and let
everyone like i made it maybe as a crash
analogy i was like look at the england
football team it's merit and it ends up
very diverse naturally because it's
merit that was my argument but i still
don't see what's so bad about that so
let's talk what we're actually talking
about nick because there's something
underneath this conversation that we all
know is there okay and we don't want to
address which is what you really pointed
out is comedy is not a meritocracy much
like the media much like anything else
and people's identity has become an
important part of whether you're
considered fit for a particular job
was that is that a fair description
yeah
yeah yeah
and you pointed this out and i think
there are two things going on and tell
me what you think about this number one
is
there are a lot of people who've bought
into the idea that because people like
you who look like you not like you but
who look like you used to be on the tv
quite a lot that now means that you
should not be given opportunities and
other people who don't look like you who
didn't have opportunities in the past
now should be given opportunities so
there's a group of people who just think
we need to flip the discrimination that
used to happen
right number one number two there's also
a lot of uh comedians who do look like
you but most comedians look like you
let's be honest because blokes are tend
to be more attracted to comedy and blah
blah as a career
who know this is happening
who feel bad about what's happening but
they have spent their whole career
pretending it doesn't exist and so when
you say there is discrimination which is
what you're really saying people are
being picked not only on on their on
their skill set
they then feel like well i've been
suppressing this [ __ ] my whole life and
this guy has now said it and now he
makes all of us look bad because we've
all been suppressing it this whole time
and they get angry at that too that's my
interpretation so you've got these two
groups which both are angry with you the
first group is angry with you for
pointing out that discrimination is
probably not a good thing
old-fashioned i know and the other one
is angry because they've been pretending
this whole time that what's happening is
right and you've kind of gone
it isn't
right so there's a yeah there's a few
layers in that
uh you're right well one is is one is
the fact that you can make the argument
that you've you've pointed out there of
it's been one way now we need to redress
the balance and that's fine you can make
the argument i was making the different
argument but you can actually make the
argument without calling me a bigger and
a [ __ ] comic i think because uh you know
that's neither here nor there whether
i'm any good or not or what my views are
you can make that argument that's fine
just make it calmly so i don't
necessarily i think that's fine if
that's what you believe the second point
is
is more sort of complex which is
the people who have known it was like
that for years so the people that
attacked me
one comic sort of mocked me and
referenced the fact that there are lots
of straight white men on tv and he
listed a series of people who have been
on since the 90s
i know you're on the tv you're a
millionaire it's well done his defense
was well we're doing well it's like yeah
we what happened is there was all these
straight white men on tv it was probably
too many of it was it was just them they
if anyone were the ones keeping other
people out now they said right now we've
got to have diversity
so a generation of people of
my generation it's like no we can't have
you now but they're still keeping all
the old white guys they haven't gone
anywhere you know it's kind of like if
the england football team still had gary
lineker in it you know i mean they're
they're they're still all there and
they're like no we're keeping our spots
but but now we're changing the rules so
those guys are very sensitive because
they know that they they're trying to
keep hold of their spot which i think is
what you're implying so they're the last
people that want to change anything
and then
and then i when it comes down to me
pointing it out i wasn't even really
pointing out i was merely reporting on
something that had happened to me which
is a key thing as well i was just
sharing something that had been sent to
me
that was it really i wasn't even making
this massive point then i mean he did
bring up martin luther king
but that was a joke that was a joke
remember jokes it was a it was at least
it was at least a wry comment you know i
wasn't seriously comparing that
i think you were making a point which is
a legitimate point to make but i was
making it in a light-hearted yeah of
course yeah and then in the paper it
sounded more serious
the funny thing is like nick nixon just
bitterly can't get work it's like guys i
left one of the best live agents in the
country i barely want to do gigs out of
london i've been desperate to not have
work for ages i've been refusing work
because it's annoying to go to leeds but
but everyone's like he's just bitter he
can't get work that's the accusation
against whenever you make a point like
that it's just immediately they attack
you and say he's rubbish at comedy and
he's bitter and he's a bigger it's like
and the idea by the way that i'm
calling me [ __ ] at comedy is a great
insult when i've done nearly 2 000 gigs
i've done gigs in preston frog and bucky
you don't come out of that thinking
you're amazing jeremy no comic is just
there thinking well i'm just amazing
like because you do so many hard gigs
you have a very realistic idea like some
days i think i'm amazing if i have a
great gig and the next day i think i'm
terrible but you are a very good comic
there's no denying that and we'll make
sure we put a little clip of you at the
top of the video so people can see you
are a very good comic well thanks man i
mean that that's up to people to judge
but that is completely irrelevant to the
argument i think he's just he's just
[ __ ] it's like that's not really the
point guys anyway and everyone knows it
happens the thing i pointed out yeah
everyone knows it whether you like it or
not i agree with it everyone knows it
happens that's why i think people are so
sensitive about it like how can he admit
this happens but everyone i know has had
some incident where they've been refused
something because of these other
characteristics other than their ability
so why is it taboo then why is it taboo
to then go this thing that we all know
happens happens but why is it that we
you know that the moment someone
makes a tweet about it makes a comment
about it references it they get shouted
down they get you know they're piled on
they all the rest of it why does that
happen
yeah it's it's a great it's just because
it's just like you say it's just a taboo
topic especially to say
that you're why it it just race is just
such a taboo topic now isn't it you
can't even say
well it also by the way and and the
requisite self-awareness was lacking in
the paper in the article i did but no
one cares about the plight of the
straight white male comedian let's be
honest straight away that's an absurd it
sounds ridiculous doesn't it because
it's not it's not that high on the list
of the world's problems like guys i'm
struggling here as a straight white bell
community when's my type you know it
does sound ridiculous and yet it is
happening to loads of people but it's
just a very unsympathetic plight
to talk about and the other thing that
happens with me is people think oh well
he's he's from public school or grammar
school he's like no no i went to a
[ __ ] comprehensive
state school in the north but apparently
people don't think that about me because
i can talk properly or something
you know they don't expect northerners
to be at a read and stuff so there's
this extra level this is what i realized
there's this extra level
everyone assumes on this thing i'm not
and andrew doyle has it all the time he
gets called a right-wing public school
straight white man who cut he's like
he's a gay
left-wing guy from a comprehensive
school and so you get there's this image
of me out there he's worked incredibly
hard right to get academic
qualifications to become a great
comedian he's right one of the hardest
working people you ever meet true andre
true he is and um exactly and i'm not
but
but i make some effort but yeah but this
you get this idea and that's
particularly unsympathetic if people
think you're a
sort of right wing public school boy
which i'm none of those things
hey kkk do you like music yes but only
if it's on bala like and we have
returned from successful day bear
hunting okay music must only be played
in group when we drink the blood of our
enemies well if you're interested in
rock music then elite by tria is a band
for you they're an alternative rock band
that stand up against cancel culture and
the creeping authoritarianism in society
they're like a combination of nine inch
nails radiohead and allison chains this
sounds good we must have them headline
bear fest in russia support truly
independent music by joining their free
fan community sign up at go dot elite by
trio.com
and get a free merch bundle that
includes an autographed photo fridge
magnet stickers guitar picks and secret
bonus gift
do you think that part of it is this
class
that the reason
you know that you got piled on the
reason that a lot of people get piled on
is if it's a you know people who come
from and they're not oxbridge educated
etc etc and if they question the
narrative it's somehow more acceptable
to pile on yeah yeah i do think there's
an element of that i think if you're
just if you're just not really known
like i'm basically unknown and so for a
famous comedian to attack me it's so
easy isn't it it's just so easy and it
doesn't lose anything they gain a few
virtue points from the industry or a few
likes on twitter and they can destroy my
week but and they can make my life a lot
harder but there's no
there's no loss for them because you're
just beating up on an unknown person
it's bullying basically it used to be
called bullying that's all it is but
it's very easy isn't it so why have we
come to a place where bullying has
become virtuous where dog piling someone
destroying their reputation is now seen
as a morally correct thing to do when
when i was a primary school teacher if
kids did that you'd be like well that's
bullying yeah yeah an arion
yeah i know that is that is the shocking
thing people can
bully online while putting hashtag be
kind and they're the good people that is
that really bothered me at the time i
was like these are the good people
allegedly and they're just not but it is
here's a really this is me being really
fair it is quite easy to join a pylon on
twitter and even accidentally because i
after that happened to me i was like
right i'm going to get really strict
about what i tweet to make sure i'm not
anything like these people
basically stop tweeting because i
realize
the way the medium is even if you quote
tweet someone even if you take a photo
some people maybe deserve it matt
hancock or someone but even him i was
like you know government officials maybe
deserve it but it's like ev it's so easy
if you just quote tweet someone go look
at this idiot but then if a thousand
people have done that that's gonna be a
very hard day for them but you don't
think about it just two seconds this
sounds like some sort of uh
advert now doesn't it for like mental
health awareness or something we should
be playing like soft piano music under
this yeah like guys think about what
you're tweeting yeah make it black and
white yeah yeah yeah
yeah there'll be a picture of you just
in the kitchen making
we've all tweeted something but do we
really think about it yeah
but you know what i mean it's very easy
to join so i become also aware of not
being like that myself and i'm not like
that but i don't even be one percent
like that because these people are scum
[Laughter]
come on these be kind people it just
blows my mind like i said it's comedian
i won't necessarily name you can all do
your research but
to go on about mental health awareness i
almost messaged him i was like
what have i done to you why did you do
this because i was just so baffled
because i've been nice to my whole girls
like why would you set 400 000 nearly
400 000 people on me
what do you think that's going to do to
me you know i just i just i almost
messaged that and then i just thought
nah i'll just
we'll we'll have a charity boxing match
one day
but it's funny you mentioned boxing
because the point i was just about to
make is i was talking to somebody who's
quite happy in the publishing industry
the other day and i i was asking them
how they manage this sort of thing
because in publishing it's very common
for people to get piled on and people
get told well we're not publishing this
book because it's got problematic
opinions or whatever and he made the
point which i thought was very astute
that
people choose to get upset about
different things so he was saying when
we publish a book by a gender critical
feminist
right people have a massive freak out
and they demand that that book is
cancelled and whatever
when we publish a book by mike tyson
a convicted rapist no one says a word
and i think your your situation actually
speaks very well to that point which is
people don't actually care that you've
done something wrong in real life what
they care about is you've exposed the
system that they support you've exposed
the ideological system that they are on
board with and you're pointing out the
floor in it
riley as you did comedically as you did
highlights that the system is flawed and
that is dangerous much more dangerous
than being a convicted rapist in their
mind do you see what i'm saying yeah
yeah yeah yeah absolutely you're
threatening their ideology yeah that's
what it's all about it's amazing isn't
it they get that that's such a big thing
like again like the attacks on gb news
it's all an ideology it's all and that's
why yeah that's why it's so serious and
so hysterical
well imagine they could just make their
argument calmly though that would be
interesting wouldn't it just make the
argument i mean but you're you're saying
it because i'm pushing the buttons of
the why is but what's underneath that
why are they so vehement about that
ideology well my opinion is that the
ideology is based on a lot of emotion a
lot of we wish the world was perfect or
we need to do this and we need to do
that and they've talked themselves into
doing a lot of things which are
blatantly wrong and unfair
but they have to pretend that that's
equity or whatever the the word is
nowadays and so they can't calmly defend
that because there is no rational
defense for it the only defense for it
is to scream and shout until anyone who
opposes either self-censors or gets
cancelled
right and yeah that's the weird thing
about idolatry isn't it you end up
supporting the ideology for its own sake
yeah and then all the all the tenants
that were supposed to go into it are
thrown out the window so you the whole
idea must be compassion if let's say
it's an electric ideology it must be
based in things like compassion and
empathy for the especially for the
underdog or the underclass or something
and then somehow that leads to attacking
me online
how is that in line with that what have
i done you know me just some unknown
comedian from a state school and it
doesn't make any sense but yeah it's all
done in the name of like say something
like equity yeah well you are the enemy
of the ideology and the ideology will
deliver compassion therefore if you
oppose it you must be destroyed and you
deserve no compassion because you're
threatening the world view the ideology
amazing just a little tweet yeah the
comedy world
isn't it comedy world dangerous
yeah it's so strange now i know like you
said like the audience probably don't
care too much about the details of the
common industry but it has got very
weird hasn't it yeah it used to speak
comedy
you were funny or not and now it's this
whole
well as was it in england since the 80s
it was i suppose it was left-wing wasn't
it it was against thatcher and stuff but
even then it didn't seem anything like
like it is now no it didn't it doesn't
seem that we have transgressive
comedians anymore you know comedians on
tv you'd think to yourself whoa i can't
believe they said that if you take the
american example you know someone like
chris rock
we or bill burr or you know you can name
lots of
american comedians you can't name that
many british ones that regularly get on
tv that say transgressive things that
come out against this ideology yeah
although even chris rock has gone on
that kind of journey from
really interesting edgy comic in the 90s
to this slightly woke last special and
is now pushing the vaccine whatever you
think about the vaccine he's now fully
on board with the establishment isn't he
so you could argue so uh he if you go
back to his 90s it's very interesting
because he'll say things like i've got
things i'm conservative about i've got
things i'm like democrat about he
wouldn't even say that now he wouldn't
even dare say that which is interesting
but yeah we definitely don't have it and
you and you guys have even stopped doing
it because of this is that right no
francis is going to carry i i this just
takes up too much of my time i'm working
on a book now and whatever but i might
come back and do my own show i'd never
do the circuit again and was it because
of busyness or was it because if you
just couldn't fit into that world uh i
hated being on the circuit from the
moment i set foot on it right uh mainly
because of the people right that you're
surrounded by uh i never had anything in
common with them but at the moment it's
just business you know and also i did my
ad um brochure in 2019 i it was it went
very well i was pleased with how it went
i kind of felt like i'd drawn that line
i'd got to that stage and i didn't have
anything left to prove really to myself
more than anything
um and now with trigonometry is a
full-time job the book i have to work on
it's taken a lot of my time so i've just
been focused on this i might come back
to you know okay and francis you're
obviously working on your your tour i'm
working on my tour but also as well i
got
i got sick of not being able to talk of
what i wanted to talk about
to to discuss the subjects i wanted to
discuss
i i really just had enough of it it got
to the point where i just felt that i
was self-censoring he's got a great ten
minutes on the muslims yeah exactly i
mean it's just all ban to make what's
there some comics doing that nicholas de
santos doing that yeah and uh nicholas
de santo ended up nearly getting fired
from his job with the bbc as well as a
result of other comedians
maybe we should cut his name out of this
game but uh but someone told me you did
you said something about it a a friend
of ours the other day said you'd you
just you'd put some tweet or something
and you just said you're welcome to it
guys i'm not i'm done with the comedy
world or something did you do yeah yeah
yeah pretty much pretty much because
i've just
there is only so long that you can play
a game where the rules are stupid where
you start to make yourself become stupid
by playing the game
right it only can go on for so long
before you have to make a value judgment
you think am i going to carry on with
this and waste time
and wait and time is precious
we there is a limited amount that we all
have
am i going to carry on doing this am i
going to carry on seeking
currying the favor of people that i have
no respect for who in ordinary life i
would not give the time of day to but
somehow because i'm in this industry i
have to play the game i have to be of
secrets and i have to listen to their
demented opinions as if they hold any
value i just don't have time for it
anymore right and was it that you just
saw so you didn't respect the people and
you saw did you see no hope in that
direction for you or you know like they
would never accept you anyway
number one they would never accept me
number two they would never accept my
politics even though actually
old school i'd probably just slightly
left of center so right on some things
in terms of culture but you know i
believe that you know there's two sexes
you know there's men and there's women
and that's it
yeah exactly yeah yeah and that doesn't
mean that we can't have respect for
trans people and we can't support them
we can't be empathetic all of those
things but you can't deny biology
and you know and if you've said that on
the comedy circuit
you would be fine you'll be finished i
wouldn't open with it
as as comedians i want to say but this
is the thing nick it's like what francis
is talking about this is the thing that
took us a few years to get our heads
around doing the show
we are genuinely not right wing but
somehow the idea that there's two sexes
or that maybe open borders isn't a
sustainable policy or the
whatever other culture war issue or not
culture worship you come up with like
the sensible rational mainstream opinion
is now like right wing right and and
it's just not no no it's just not i'm
probably closer to a social democrat or
something i realize exactly
but but in the culture sphere which is
incredibly progressive
to to use their term yeah
the moment you you drift anywhere from
that you are immediately considered you
know evil bigot like like you you find
yourself in this position and so
the truth is life is sure as francis
says and all is going to happen you're
going to live a few more years and then
you're going to die that's it
well what happened i had a similar thing
to francis where
what bothered me is comedians telling me
for years oh be careful about that mate
don't say that yeah not even on stage
just off stage some of my opinions that
i like to put or did like to put on
twitter in the past not so much now but
i just speak my mind but they'd all say
oh man don't say that and at a certain
point i thought do you really want to
live like that isn't that cowardice do
you mean as a man do you really want to
go around living or as a person but
especially do you really want to just
for whoever has watched this but do you
really want to go around living
in a state of fear about what you say
all the time exactly because like you
say some person who you don't respect
anyway might see it and ban you from
some imaginary thing you might have got
in six years yeah i'm like i can't live
like that yeah that's how most comedians
live all comedians live like right and
they always tell me well i wouldn't say
that
and the things i'm saying are not even
bad but they you know but they're just
an opinion and it's like oh
about everything i'm like i can't live
like that and the world and the comedy
world forces you into that francis i
remember one when we in the early
there's a trigonometry he messaged me
saying i don't think you should say this
yeah and that's not because he's a bad
guy it's because we're all in that world
yeah yeah yo you feel like you're
constantly being watched by other people
who may give you an opportunity an
opportunity being a gig and [ __ ]
cuntington on c for a hundred quid right
on that saturday night or whatever it is
yeah 150. or that one day you'll get on
the apollo exactly yeah and get
once but the thing is you want right you
know and i got i got the whole thing
handed to me on a platter one day
because i
i was
walking to a gig and some guy was
i had an altercation with some guy on
the street who called me a [ __ ]
right which which is i apologize now
he does that joke every time good well
done
and i got home and i got an email from a
comedy promoter saying
hey constantine i'm sorry we're going to
have to cancel your spot this saturday
because we've got too many straight
white men on the bill
right and i was like okay
you know now i see do you know what i
mean
it's it's just uh
but you didn't tweet that no that was
that that was smart um so you're getting
it from both sides you're getting
attacked
it's a joke man the whole thing
ironically the comedy industry is a joke
the the the structure of it is a joke uh
the whole thing of it it's a rigged game
and
you know it's like george carlin to say
and you ain't in it it's a small club
and you ain't in it and that's fine
because now luckily we have our own
tools that we can create our own [ __ ]
but you ain't in the club
yeah i mean now i'm thinking i've said
too much i was there was a slight chance
i could have been in the club but um
no no because what i started doing yeah
i'm the same i started just speaking my
mind and doing all the
and there's other other channels for
that wham's me is during the lockdown
without that like you said like sort of
voice of like oh what was the comedy
world thing because i had gone because i
was not doing comedy and i was just at
home i then started writing articles for
spiked and i suddenly wrote seven i was
like this is brilliant and they're quite
good and i was like i can do this which
i never would have done before and they
would be called you know
right wing by the comedy industry even
though they're marxist so that's another
weird one to figure out
some of them are marxists so i started
writing these articles then i did talk
radio then i did gb news and these are
the things that if you get cancelled
they're going to still have me on
because they probably don't care because
i'm probably being canceled for
something stupid anyway so i just stick
with the things that like me and where i
can go but yeah but it's unfortunate
because it'd be nice to
be on tv hey i'm doing gb news that's
nice isn't it and people go yeah well
done without having to feel weird about
it and it'd be nice if you could just do
both imagine that if you could just do
bbc and gv news and no one thought it
was a big deal because it's all let's be
honest it's all showbiz really isn't it
yeah isn't it all really showbiz isn't
it really there's not that much
differences there between gb news and
bbc really is there it's a person
reading out some opinions or some news
is it really that different
i think there is a difference i think
there is a difference there is a
difference but
i don't know if it's as big as we think
i mean someone once said to me uh jesus
was in showbiz slightly blasphemous but
i saw it
[Laughter]
isn't everyone isn't aren't we all a
little bit in show over here just doing
the same isn't it just a person saying
an opinion on the tv yeah look there is
a good point to be made about that
the thing that i find frustrating is not
really the comedy industry though i hope
they all burn and die right and
hopefully i'll get some vitamins and
hopefully i get successful enough and
rich enough that one day that i can make
that dream come to fruition right
but
it's what happens to the art form that's
what really annoys me is what happens to
the art form because when we both
started and i imagine you as well i've
fell in love with the idea of the
comedians this sort of transgressive
force saying the unsayable tackling
subjects that we you know that we all
knew to be true but didn't dare speak
that was the role of the comedian the
hicks the prior the carlin the bill burr
yeah and i'm thinking where are those
guys going to come from now yeah
where are they going to come from that's
what the comedian was a sort of loner
figure telling the truth getting last
that's what it was all about that's what
we watched growing up now it's this
other thing it has to be all everything
has to be fair and representative and i
yeah i got in trouble saying it why does
comedy have to even be representative i
don't even get it it's just why can't it
just be comedy i don't understand it's
once it became this important social
media i mean in this country it happened
with michael mcintyre they found out the
bbc found out we could make this cheap
programming relatively cheap loads of
people watch it and they love it and
then they thought hmm how can we turn
this into social engineering you know
what i mean it wasn't enough just to say
oh it's comedy it became too important
so it became a tool a political tool as
opposed to just being the art form that
it is that it used to be yeah and it's
do you think we're ever going to get
back to that time do you think we're
ever going to get going to get back to
that time where we see these
transgressive figures
and they and they become mainstream
again
or do you think it's different now the
the media landscape is different the
internet has made things different and
that's just the way it's going to be
yeah i i do struggle to see how we get
back to that because like we're in this
like you say internet well we're in this
it's this fractured culture everyone has
their little niche which is good in a
way but you don't have that centralized
narrative so it is hard to see how you
get these big comedians who are just
trying
it happens a little bit like you say in
the u.s you do still have them a bit
don't you occasionally
with someone like bill burr although
he's a bit tamer than he was but you do
have it i i can't i wonder about that
that's why i was thinking about this
split between live at apollo and comedy
unleashed i was thinking can these two
ever come back together and just be
comedy again because a lot of the comedy
at columbia is just normal comedy
yeah and that's what actually all we're
trying to bring back because it just
this reminds me of um a tweet a while
ago by i think it was richard tyson he
was saying
it was on the radio him and lawrence fox
saying we're going to have a pub and
it's going to have british food no masks
blah blah free speech all these things i
was like yeah fair enough and right wing
comedy and i was like hang on that's not
that's not the answer no no we don't
nobody needs right wing comedy right
just you just need good comedy just
comment it that's it that's it and
whoever brings that will will get
respect as like oh these guys brought us
back normal comedy but it so if that's
the right wing then great they'll get a
win there but but yeah we don't need
right the the antidote to all this
whatever so-called work company whatever
you want to call it is just comedy
and that's what people want when some of
my youtube videos that do okay from
comedy unleash people like all the
positive comments are all about oh
proper comedy again that's all it is
that's all people want
just normal comedy again yeah yeah it's
this idea that you know that we we're
all in separate factions so now we do
comedy to cater to left-wing woke people
now we need comedy to cater to
right-wing people right i don't care and
i don't think the majority of audience
members i don't care about comedian's
political views right i disagree with
stewart lee politically i think his
political views are demented i think
he's a very good comedian yeah brilliant
comedian
i will sit and watch stuart lee and
disagree with him and enjoy his comedy
right right exactly and that that should
be a normal a normal view i was thinking
about i did a gig in cambridge a while
ago and afterwards a guy comes up to me
and goes oh you're a really good mate no
you're really good it was really nice to
see you weren't just sort of doing like
a rant like the others were all like it
was right you sort of do it and i just
went jokes and he was like that was it i
was doing jokes
i was just doing comedy but everyone
else was doing just a political rant
about why the audience should feel bad
and it's like all i'm doing is not that
i'm just sort of pretending that doesn't
exist you know what i mean and even in
if you mentioned edinburgh even there
you can get reviewed almost on what
you're not yeah like the year that the
me too thing was a big thing if you
didn't address that you'd almost be
attacked for that but all you're really
doing what i've just been doing in my
company is just pretending none of that
exists and occasionally i'll reference
it if i'm at commonly unleashed i'll do
a sort of political or culture war type
reference but mainly i'll just do my
comedy as if that's not a thing
but it's more for me it's more my
apparent off-stage music kept me in
trouble but anyway here we are do you
think that audiences are just they're
getting to the point where and this is
what i worry about i was talking you
know with
a friend of mine and we sat down with
watching this uh comedian on the latest
uh stand-up show and i was foaming at
the mouth and rage and i was saying as a
punter who's just looking at that he's
taking the soul very well but
do i need to send you one of these
messages are you okay oh yeah do you
want to swap chairs with nick we're
gonna interview you about your anger
mate yeah no all you're gonna see my
better side left side is my better one
john a swat
but he was making the point that when he
was watching this comedian who wasn't
particularly good
that he would just look at it
at that and go oh that's what stand up
is now i'm not going to go and watch it
because it's not good that's what i
worry about as well yeah it can only
damage the whole medium for everyone and
everyone knows this actually even the
agents know this even the big agents
that have that run things like live at
the apollo have said the bbc are
destroying this because the agent
doesn't want to destroy because they
want to make money yeah but the bbc has
their agenda and you know
it's this public thing and they've got
this social engineering agenda so yeah
the agents don't want it the audiences
don't want it i don't think the
comedians really want it most of them
and yet it happens anyway well there we
are nick unfortunately we've got to wrap
up mate all right we've got one more
question for you that we always ask but
i wanted to ask
what's next for you what are your plans
what are you going to do
my plan is really a lot more gb news may
as well may as well double down on that
while we're there um
i've got a column and bright bar yeah
yeah yeah and i'm still doing uh stand
up i'm still out there doing the gig so
that's it really this is just to do more
of that do more writing
you know articles and stuff and and and
keep doing stand-up and
yeah it might because i've still got
clubs that book me and a lot and love me
so that's
so that's great i'll keep doing those
and just you know this weird little
niche i mean i don't know where it leads
because it's this new niche which is
sort of the comedy unleashed
world of whatever that is so this is new
niche i'm just exploring and i'll see
where it goes that's my hope that that
actually the the current kind of
pressure cooker and
restriction restrictive culture
can get pushback from something like
comedy unleashed where you get people
coming through who are actually willing
to be transgressive and when the numbers
are there to back it up eventually it
takes off as the new counterculture
that's my hope that's my hope as well
yeah but it's a strange world you don't
really know what that career is you're
just in the dark really you're just sort
of hacking away just you just because it
doesn't really there's no structure that
exists there
because it's a new platform like we did
that comedy in each pilot and they're
going to try and sell it we have to make
our own
distribution platforms and things like
that as you guys know so yeah and but i
think that's very exciting because when
you create your own platform you have
true freedom to be who you are say what
you want write the comedy that you want
because you're no longer answerable to
these gatekeepers right
right or
i'm just hoping for like better
gatekeepers as well like you know things
like gb news talk radio spike these
things i do
they're they're sort of gatekeepers on
it in a way but in a much different way
but like you say or just do it yourself
which you guys are doing which i should
probably do more of but hey
but nick thank you so much for coming on
the show uh before we do some questions
for locals we always ask our one final
question which is what's the one thing
we're not talking about but we really
should be
now what's the one thing do you mean we
as a culture yes yeah
what's the one thing we're not talking
about well i thought it was um straight
white male comedians not getting gigs
but
that was a huge mistake
that turned out to be a huge state
you're not allowed to talk about that
doesn't we almost can't talk about
anything can we i mean there's almost
nothing you can talk about in the
culture now without getting in trouble
so i don't know i mean the part of the
culture that we inhabit we kind of talk
about whatever we want on here so
far away
well the thing is everyone is talking
about so like this trans thing springs
to mind people get in huge trouble about
that
i just think i think
i think we are talking about everything
but anything you talk about
there's going to be two sides there's
going to be immense conflict on twitter
straight away i mean there's this idea
of the silent majority
i'm not even totally sure it exists
but i think we are i can't think of
anything we're not talking about because
we are someone is talking about
everything but as soon as you say
anything you're going to have immense
pushback and immense hateful online but
i can't think of one topic that's not
brought up i can just i just think of a
range of topics that aren't you're not
allowed to talk about which is virtually
everything
but in the mainstream yeah but everyone
everyone is talking about everything but
but they're just but they're not allowed
to talk about any of it that's my
position does that make any sense yeah
yeah so i guess what you're saying is
there are lots of things that you're not
supposed to talk about but people do
talk about it but it's scary to do so
because there's the risk of cancellation
whatever it is right right so we're
always talking about everything we're
always talking about race we're talking
about transitions we're talking about
all issues we actually are talking about
them but in a very in a very heated
atmosphere where you can't actually talk
freely about them so that's what i think
is happening yeah that's a very good
point it's a very good point nick if
people want to find your work online
where would be the best place to do that
well it's at nickdixon comic on twitter
nick d-i-x-o-n comic on twitter
instagram all those things i've got my
spikes articles i'm on medium nick dixon
you find me i'm doing you get i get paid
if you read my media articles so they're
inspirational article they're more like
uplifting i did one about my fitness
journey guys it's very uplifting so yeah
but acne dickson comic
and uh you'll find it all all right nick
thanks so much for coming on and thank
you for watching and listening at home
we'll see you very soon with another
brilliant interview like this one or raw
show all of them go out 7pm uk time and
if you're on the move and you want a
little bit of trigonometry in your life
it's also available as a podcast take
care and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below